scenw work is interesting cuz in when we
talk about scene work all we really need
is a character or we need more than one
character but the character needs
conflict so we want to keep our
characters in as much conflict as
possible and there's a film I always
bring up to my students who and I make
them watch it over and over again
because it's a Little Miss Sunshine
carries the torch of scene by scene of
hitting conflict shifting power Dynamics
which is also another word for shifting
status I feel like that comes up more in
TV shows and TV scripts the shifts of
status and it's so powerful that when we
see it in a movie um it it's it's pretty
cool so when I'm rewriting a scene I go
over who has status in the scene and
then is there a way to play with it so
I'll do an example of a cop
interrogating a um a suspect so there's
a cop and he's interroga ating a there
it is a cop interrogating a suspect and
the cop has high status and the suspect
is in handcuffs the suspect may even be
crying and the suspect has low status so
when you're watching a scene think about
power dynamics and think about status
because that's what actors are thinking
about and that's what writers are
thinking about when they're writing and
actors are thinking about that when
they're playing
together but we can shift we can shift
that dynamic because in let's say in the
same scene the suspect has information
that the cop wants so then the cop
realizes this and maybe the suspect
smiles and the cop slams his fist on the
table and he's upset as the suspect is
not giving him this information and all
of a sudden the suspect has higher
status and the cop is lower status the
cop wants something from the suspect
needs something from the suspect and the
suspect is giving it up so when you're
watching films keep an eye out on the on
the status and power dynamics and watch
how the protagonists can go in and out
of high status and low status in scenes
like in uh here's the example of um
Little Miss Sunshine When We're
introduced to Richard Richard is Richard
is talking about his life coaching his I
I forget what it's like five principles
for being the amazing man you are meant
to be he's commanding the stage as he's
you know eyeing the crowd and going over
his presentation and then the camera
turns around and it shows us how many
people are in the audience and there's
like maybe 10 and he gets a tepid
Applause so the director the director
gave us a power Dynamic shift we thought
we were seeing a very high status person
almost talking to a stadium of people
and then we realize he's low status and
it's practically a conference room and
no one really cares what he's saying
it's it's a lot of fun and that's and
that and that's when Richard goes back
down to low status refuse to lose that's
what it is right the nine
Concepts and speaking of Little Miss
Sunshine of all characters in the film
who has the biggest sort of status
shift yeah that well our the the
character with that has the most Arc is
Richard the dad because and when we look
at little miss shine Richard is the
protagonist um because he's the one that
needs to take the journey and to learn
so when we get to act three he has to
Showdown with himself to finally get out
of this facade that he's creating as a
you know guy with a master plan and
everyone needs to succeed and he makes a
fool of himself at the end with his
daughter which just is that scene
always um really gives me chills when I
watch it but um but his his he's trying
to get high status the whole time when
he um when he gets into his low status
and kind of saves his daughter from
having embarrassment alone that's when
he has challenged himself and he has won
because he's be he's lost his status but
he's become the father he's supposed to
be for the family and the whole family
comes together when Dad kind of realizes
that wait a second I need to save my
daughter
that's beautiful and just real quick
which character has the least Arc in
Little Miss Sunshine you know Tony
Colette's character the wife really has
it she feels like a placeholder and I
don't know if in early rewrites if she
had an arc because a lot of these
characters have arcs um there's Dwayne
who has a oh that yeah that's a great
Ensemble photo uh the father has an arc
I mean he's a junkie and then he dies
sure um and I know and Little Miss and
the the young girl who plays Little Miss
Sun uh little the little going to the
beauty contest she doesn't have much of
an arc either she's kind of like a
placeholder um so there's there's a lot
of fun happening um I think between
Dwayne and the brother um through a lot
of the film and that might be they may
be hitting the philosophical points of
what the writer was intending to kind of
give the moral of the story throughout
I'm just coming off a memory I haven't
watched it in about a year because
that's my first quarter students we have
to watch it over and over and over again
and it's so worth it yeah I want to go
back to it it's been a while thank you I
want to see it what are storytelling
cheats and and which are some that are
fun to use storytelling cheats I'm glad
you asked cuz I have some notes about
okay
um if you want to like feeling sympathy
for for a character some ways to get
right to feeling sympathetic Blake
Snider wrote the book save the cat so
there so there's that's a way to get
sympathy immediately immediately save a
cat here's another example let's say a
mom's just trying to clean the house
before her in-laws arrive have her step
on a Lego have her have her step on like
a tack or a nail um when we when we when
we do something with the palm of the
hand when we cut the palm of the hand or
the bottom of the foot as we're watching
it we've all experienced that pain
especially on the foot the bottom of the
foot hurts so bad right and it
immediately gives us an emotional
response where we're like we've been
there we've done that so that's an
element to add to a scene if we look at
Minority Report in a Minority Report
everyone is scanned by their eyeballs
and so when Tom Cruz is on the run and
he's wanted for the future murder he has
to get rid of his eyeballs it it's so I
mean it me just that idea alone brings
massive conflict and then and so think
about what you can do with the eyeballs
can you touch the eye can you poke the
eye what I through that whole operation
scene of Minority Report with Tom Cruz
it we're we're like losing our minds
sure mhm and then if we go back to um
Little Miss Sunshine it's the there's a
lovely thing that the writer does which
is he gives Dwayne The Vow is silence
Dwayne didn't have to have that vow I
don't know what draft of the script
where the writer went you know what uh
because the writer of the script in
early drafts could have just had Dwayne
upset and mad at his parents and it
would have been fine but he has a vow of
silence and it escalates his tragedy so
when he finds out he's collar blind and
he can't become an pilot I think he
wants to be a pilot and you can't be a
pilot when you call her blind when the
that plot Point happens that's the first
time he speaks and when he speaks after
he hasn't been speaking of throughout
the whole film we pay immediate
attention so it's like it's symbolic on
so many level
levels and the other thing about Little
Miss Sunshine is the VW van
situation just make make make the VW ban
only start in second
gear what what a Fant fantastic story
device cuz it makes it um it makes the
family push the van and they all have to
jump in the van so there's danger
involved there's the family just being
disgusted they have to do this and and
it's a device that brings us to the very
end of the film it's a device cuz they
hate working together when this happens
it's drudgery through the film when
they've come together in the last scene
as they push the van through the parking
lot they're they're pushing the van as a
family all of a sudden we see them as
they they've all kind of been reborn
into becoming a family and so watching
them push the van is a whole new
experience for us and
Them